a lot of groups have been talking about
the eurozone crisis whether it's going
to have a global impact or not we've
been totally focused in our discussions
today on the global cooperation needed
to backstop European efforts to deal
with the crisis I think the most
interesting discussions we've had about
what it is that the Chinese government
would require in return for a deal that
it contributes to a global fund for
growth and recovery what it is that the
Brazilian government would demand from
from Europe in reply what it is that
other oil States and emerging economies
would require this time round if they
were going to contribute to a global
solution for example some of our Chinese
interlocutors talked about the deal to
China being one where they get more
power in global institutions more trade
access to European markets where they
get a biggest say in how the funds are
actually being used it's been
interesting seeing how in practice if
you wanted to put together a global plan
for helping Europe overcome its crisis
this could be termed that it's going to
be quite costly in terms of compromises
in other areas